citizens of the reject Nation Greg and
what's your name I'm John I think we
just saw Black Adam at a special
screening at this building right here
the Dolby Laboratories building and uh
we got to shoot this quick before
Burbank PD finds US hey Burbank we're
coming to Crime
the hierarchies reviews
did you clear this with the city did you
pay Black Adam now if you guys haven't
seen the trailer Dwayne Johnson's
passion project for DC and it's it's
like the dark version of Shazam that's
all you pretty much need to know been
waking after uh thousands five thousand
years they said it several times in this
movie 5 000 years he wants to protect
his City conduct black Adam's been
awakened and so Justice Society of
America comes in because he's a he's
like a nuclear bomb waiting to go off
Superman level threat Amanda Waller's
always warning about exactly so the
Justice side he sent in there
um okay well where to begin with this
film I would say that for starters one
of the things that surprised me the most
about it was that post-credits scene man
if that wasn't ruined for you boy would
it have been awesome if it wasn't
everywhere Dwayne Johnson himself pretty
much wasn't confirming that whatever was
put out about that post-credit scene is
true if it wasn't something you've been
told to expect it was a great
post-credit scene it is awesome we'll
talk about it some other time because it
was like you know what even though this
was ruined for me it's pretty sweet yeah
I'm so excited to be here right yeah I
still will remember this moment in terms
of the movie itself the thing that
really surprised me was how they
actually really let Black Adam be pretty
violent he is pretty brutal in the
trailer they do have that one line where
he's having a standoff with Hawkman and
hawkman's like uh Heroes don't kill he's
like I do and in this movie he kills a
lot there's a lot of actual there's a
lot of death actually and I had that
exact thought at one point like a lot of
people were dying right away he's
killing a lot of people in this movie
and it's pretty sweet and they get
pretty creative with bordering on that
PG-13 to R rating you believe it was cut
down from an Arya yeah it's not like
those Sony movies you know uh where
they're like he's an anti-hero beer not
really you want to be good this guy
doesn't want to be good he doesn't want
to be good and he's actually you know
straight up I mean granted he's not
killing like good people and a lot of
the visual effects are pretty Dynamite
like there's so much of it that at times
it becomes very overwhelming at the same
time time though there are some very
very impressive visual effects with
Black Adam like I actually really
enjoyed the way they chose to capture
how he flies you know that a lot of the
way we're just sort of hovering up
forward it's kind of like playing a
video game character to a certain extent
and I thought that was great to bring it
to life the Justice Society of America
everything with Hawkman looked awesome
Dr Fate he looked great right he looks
incredible yeah especially the way they
realize his various powers and the
choices they make visually to separate
themselves from not being too much like
Doctor Strange yeah you know they
actually managed to make it so you're
not even thinking about that the music
choices by Lauren Buffy which sounds
like a werewolf to me I thought the
music was also wonderful the movie
itself
was fine it was a fine movie yeah I
honestly it was pretty messy in a lot of
ways and I think like Dwayne Johnson
actually does do an all right job you
know it was something that I was very
questionable about I didn't go
all I see is Black Adam when I watch
this movie and it didn't necessarily
reinvent the Dwayne Johnson wheel in
terms of acting but yeah I mean he does
sell a much more hard line violent
character he doesn't have to rely on his
charm in this movie which is nice no
he's not really a character who Smiles
like there's humor to be had with the
character but some of that is with its
Fish Out of Water qualities and the
deadpan qualities yeah yeah he's he's a
very stoic character which which is
fitting for this guy Dwayne Johnson
definitely played a character you know
what I mean was I aware I was watching
Dwayne Johnson for most of it yeah I was
aware the character he should play but I
appreciated what he was doing yeah I
appreciate that he really played a
character instead of just relying on
Dwayne Johnson charm this is gonna sound
like a nitpick but it's not all right I
want you to think about this for one
second he wakes up after 5 000 years and
he's speaking English in a country where
that's not what they're speaking you
know speaking English he's got an
American accent and no one's bringing
this up no one's questioning why it
immediately pulled me out of the realm
of believability on what they're doing
because I couldn't move past that it was
ancient Shazam magic translates that's
that's the power they don't tell you
about if that's something they don't
tell me they should have mentioned no no
yeah it is a little bit silly that way
it's very distracting and I think the
problem with Dwayne Johnson's
performance here is while I appreciate
what he was going for I didn't really
feel the internal struggle they kept
telling me he's having no he's just kind
of stoic the whole movie is saying you
could be a hero Black Adam and he's like
now I'm no hero
and that's about his first his whole
internal struggle is I have no problem
killing people but I guess I have a few
people around me who I would benefit
from working from so I guess I should
kill less people it's sort of his whole
journey you know while I think that
there's some charming performances to be
had like Aldous Hodges is Hawkman here
yeah this Hodges brings a lot to his
performance like he's really giving it
his all Pierce Brosnan kind of just
slips into this poetic magician
all-knowing kind of role of Dr Fate I
think he's perfectly cast and then Noah
centineo and quintessa Swindell are in
the movie well mainly mainly Cyclone is
yeah I think they gave a decent Charming
amount to Noah centineo he brought some
humor to it that was he was funny he's
more of a character than she is and yes
he has bits that are identifiable and
that are fun to watch come back yeah
it's like watching Spider-Man
she though is nothing in this film I
don't blame the actress I really blame
the writing of this film I wanted to see
more of her yeah main takeaway I had
with the experience by the end of it
because at first it starts off clunky
and then it started smoothing out and I
thought oh it's one of those movies that
probably gets better as it goes but then
it went right back into no this is
pretty clunky this is a messy movie it's
very very messy and it feels almost
outdated with a lot of the types of
tropes they decided to play into
especially third act wise especially
with the villain it feels very
perfunctory and com and especially the
villain first how cool the villain looks
it does feel like oh yeah that's right
we have to I guess have a villain in
this that's not just Black Adam trying
to become good even that quality feels
underwritten that's the main takeaway I
had was the scenes that are not action
feel very rushed and there's so much
information being thrown my way that it
becomes about just keeping up with the
most Baseline piece of here's what you
need to know about this character to
kind of give a [ __ ] but you're not
really gonna give a [ __ ] but you hear
maybe you will but you you probably
won't yeah you probably won't and it's
so underwritten and the editing is just
all over the place well that's the thing
is Yo Macaulay Sarah's style like when
the movie is Flowing I think his style
really works because he likes a lot of
shots a lot of editing a lot of coverage
but when the movie is you know it's a
movie you could tell has been reworked
and when you're in one of those patches
his style does not help itself out so
then it feels extra messy at those times
yeah it's a brick it has like some of
that cool Zack Snyder slo-mo [ __ ] that
you you love and needle drops and needle
drops Galore which surprisingly worked
for me in a movie that I didn't think if
you told me needle drops were in here
those scenes I thought were fun they
were fun needle drops to be had I
thought it did nicely to emulate Zack
Snyder in in enough ways to kind of make
it cohesive with what has come before in
the you know Snyder verse line of the DC
EU but not so much that it's like oh
that's all they're trying to do or oh
that's the only idea they have and
there's nothing else brought to the
table but it does feel very much like no
no we want to reinforce this Vision
because I wanted to walk away just going
you know what it was a schlocky fun but
it doesn't quite feel that way to me
there are times of it where it just felt
kind of monotonous I think there is like
an equal amount of things that are kind
of fun and unique and especially you
know looking at Dwayne Johnson in a more
harsh heavy role you know like that's
interesting but then on the opposite
side you have a bunch of things that
feel very requisite you eventually not
only do you have your villain tacked on
but you also get your requisite you know
Army that we can easily kill because
there's vaguely Supernatural and there's
not going to be any blood or whatever uh
you got the family element of like I
lost my wife and kid and now I've got
this surrogate wife and kid I feel like
they could have chosen some more unique
aspects I know the the thing with his
family comes from the origin of the
character but it's kind of mostly what
his backstory is for the whole entire
thing you know you get some lore with
the Shazam Wizards and all that stuff
but it really feels like there's not a
lot of meat on the bone when it comes to
the characters and the most interesting
idea the movie has is just about the
thin line between good and evil and the
way like the Justice Society looks at
everything in those terms when this is
about you know a more gray world and you
know we need to be in charge of how we
see that Justice through but even that's
just like one conversation and it never
comes back and it doesn't really like
imbue the movie with a sense of weight
it's just like oh I guess points for
having an idea and putting it in the
movie between fights the parts where the
care seem to most go into it was the
action scenes because the action's cool
the action's great it's it's like really
great action and I feel like that's the
point that we're past with superhero
movies now that we at least ought to be
where he is a little bit more past the
action scenes that's not one of things
you have to get right yes guys there's
this freaking Sky Beam at the end of
this movie that's what I mean by
outdated there are things that felt like
this was the kind of movie I would watch
in the late 90s early 2000s the whole
movie feels like the Aries fight with
Wonder Woman Kind of imagine if you just
took that part of act 3 and stretched it
into an entire movie and that's kind of
what this feels like I didn't feel like
the movie really brought anything new
other than a cool new set of powers
seeing that brought to life was fun and
there's there is fun to be had the
movie's messier than I expected it to be
I think it falls flat in a lot of areas
that I think you thought it was bringing
dramatic heft to in some ways it's about
what I expected in other ways it's a
little bit of a letdown and in other
things they did better than I expected
them to do it's a little of everything
it's a little bit better here and a
little bit worse here than I expected
you know it's a mixed bag yeah overall I
like whatever if you're gonna watch or
go watch it I I feel like you don't have
to see it in the theaters even though I
feel like some of the action scenes are
worth more watching in the theaters than
watching at home for the first time if
you're just watching to keep up with the
continuity watch it at home if you care
about any of the characters and if you
care about the action go see it in the
theaters because that's where the best
parts of the movie Will Shine the
brightest but yeah it's not really such
a game changer that you gotta rush out
didn't see it you know no I feel like
I've seen this movie already I do too
like this is about by the numbers as
you'd expect in every way and sometimes
flatter than I would expect but that's
where we're at it's fine it's a good
skateboarding I have a kid actors
there's so many laughable moments in
there oh a lot of ADR too oh well what
do you know well you take things too
seriously Greg all righty well subscribe
click that Bell are you excited for the
follow-up film where you know what the
follow-up's gonna be and I'm excited I'm
still excited for it I feel like it'd be
cool Shazam
[Music]